et bien rond jour les amigos d'aller
vous il ya quelques jours j'ai sorti une
faq dans laquelle je répondais à vos
questions puisque c'est une fois en
question c'est le concept de la vidéo et
en cherchant des questions pertinentes
je suis tombé sur une question qui a
attiré mon attention la question était
la suivante sais tu que tu as une
fanbase sur la relation entre maxence et
toi pour plus d'information va faire un
tour sur int g alors je les ai pas vus
dans la vidéo puisque je me suis dit
attends là il ya un truc surpuissant
derrière j'ai fait deux trois recherche
google est effectivement il ya un vrai
des liens entre maxence et moi et
aujourd'hui on va découvrir tout ce
délire en vidéo avec maxence le grand
l'unique à je t'aime
oups pardon fallait pas je le dise il y
a des gens qui s'amusent à dire que nous
sommes secrètement au coût de maxence et
ça ça me laisse beaucoup
il faut qu'on mène l'enquêté maxence
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
d'où ça vient je te présente le compte
entre luxe et qui comme on peut le
remarquer la fusion parfaite de nos deux
prénoms oui ça marche bien c'est aussi
une marque de peinture
alors je sais pas pourquoi ces photos-là
particulèrement mais je n'ai rien par
exemple à on peut apercevoir un contact
tactile imminent et j'ai l'impression
que ça les excite beaucoup venaient de
se faire on va découvrir cet univers
bien photo après photo où il ya des
volailles il ya des vidéos rex
incroyable ils sont trop mignons début
ils n'avaient pas encore trouvé l'uqac
106 et une instruction a pris car les
hashtag lucasson ça pas mal sans la page
s'appelle encore luc action optique h la
fête la fête ambiance
[Applaudissements]
il y a eu un contact tactile et je crois
que ça va plus on s'était fixé sur mes
cheveux - excusez moi j'ai pas
narcissique on en parle de ses yeux qui
brillent très amoureux de moi seulement
il savait qu'il ya deux jours avant
cette vidéo tu m'as trompé ben moi paris
laissant vidéo tu veux quoi deux jours
avant je t'avais grillé avec martin
dalmat était venu avec lui martin vient
ok c'est un tribunal était venu avec lui
tu voulais appeler pour me juger devant
les gens ce qu'il fait mais c'est juste
un massage martin jeudi soutenir mais
arrête de tout chez toi là pour le coup
c'est vous qui me soutiennent vous avez
fait l'amour martin tweet
waouh j'ai une très belle tati cette
photo j'avais pas vu sa main à ces
attentes non c'est vrai à tanger ratés
notamment sur mon épaule mais quitte à
maille sur vodafone il avait tant
d'honneurs théodore nuque leurs sourires
non mais y'a plus rien quoi juste ans
horizon une photo où il y en a tant
besoin
un compliment sur le cac le cas tu sens
bon maxence voilà tu as de beaux chevaux
sam a ravivé des bons souvenirs
c'est ça ma laideur et je sais ce que ça
te fait dire ça c'était un peu plus beau
moment justin voulait puisque la veille
avait encore une sono martin qui paraît
toujours amené martin sheen énorme et
mais qui s'inscrit juste un pote mais
c'est pas grave c'est tous les jours et
des massages martin dans ton téléphone
c'est un poteau en béton pas tu l'aurais
d'écart tous les jours tu mais je t'aime
avec un est logique heures hebbadj et à
maurice méthon comme tu l'as dit un loeb
et tu fais exprès maxence minimum mais
tu dis pas un pote tu dis quoi tu dis
pas un à un ses personnages leurs
excuses
j attends désolé je t'adore mais tu lui
dit mais ces tags mais tu es en train de
te justifier ça montre bien qu un blème
on se voit très vite ces trois points de
suspension je sais pas trop qu'on se
verra trois petits points comme si tu
savais quand est-ce que tu allé le voir
pour les trois petits points veut dire
je sais quand je vois mais on va pas
dire ici parce qu'on cache un truc à lui
car j'attends je revois un message à mes
produits sa marge à deux doigts bombe et
judy donc pas la masia dans ce volume et
4.5 sommation et je mets des clins
d'oeil quand il m'a répondu c'est un peu
chaud voleurs
c'est l'excellente eh bien regardez
partie une épaule comme ça voilà en fait
je crois que je regardais un tueur on
montre une photo
ouais c'est la preuve qu'ils me toucher
l'épaule franchement c'est ce qui
m'avait séduit d'abord enfin c'est ce
qui a fait que j'ai on est devenus potes
et enfin j'ai kiffé la fin mai après la
photo suivante avec full love mac ou pas
le mal est bien cool le bonheur dans les
yeux de maxence oui parce qu il était au
dessus tout était content je pense qu'on
est avec eux best of mais moi j'ai enfin
j'étais avec ton copain sympa qu'on n'a
pas non plus hésité
bah si ça contribue parce que sans toi
je m'appuierai et c'est tout c'est juste
matériel entre annonce du coup ils
tombent aux teutons bon compagnon voile
jeu quatre aces 4 mais tu fin d'un
moment à dos c'est pas mal jusqu'à lille
s'est échinée m'a pas fait si samedi
leur relaxe
moi j'appelle ça avec serge van damme à
puce et l'udc
add on est d'accord qu'il ya c'est la
vidéo est bien j'aurai en pâture aux
extraits quoi ils sont ensemble jeu des
lois et qu'à mon avis ça faisait un
moment qu'on n'avait pas fait
d'apparition classant on agir seulement
des apparitions privées non enfin même
si quand on fait des soirées entre amis
tiers c'est un truc privée je parlais
pas de continuer à s' est une autre
vidéo un beau chien peut voit demain on
a décidé de doter les boutons tout où
elles sont c'est que ce genre de regard
vers le cap est amoindrie et beaucoup
ont du coup fait que tu étais pas loin
et c'était marrant que je te regarder
quoi joyeux noël à tous merci pour tout
se fait seulement deux semaines que j'ai
seconde j'ai déjà fait des rencontres
formidables maxence just begun maxence
clan hallyday plus pointilleux plus
comptes familiaux du camaq 106 squeeze
big oil et rien pour un pied la chute
jeudi aucun rapport c'est génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est urgent cette image est fantasmé
tous ces gens
[Musique]
je sais quoi du coup ça c'est du cash
pour la matière le but lassé de se
moquer du truc dont justement donné tort
à ceux qui croient ça c'est pas d'avs où
il faut se moque évoquons ce genre à
céder ouf de croire que c'est possible
s'est passé mais le montage et fort un
bravo à toi mec c'est incroyable ils
prennent le temps de faire le montage
tellement crédible à mes mecs c'est ça
la vraie photo il ya clairement un
délire à propos de nous deux va
continuer 20 média qui peut imaginer que
éventuellement d'en rassembler tous faim
c'est marrant quoi puis si c'était le
cas enfin je savais ce qui ferait pas de
ou froides en mairie dépôt twill bras ça
arrive quand même genre nous on tourne
et qu'on a on tourne avec des sauts avec
martin très souvent dans la chambre à
côté attentes en tant qu'étudiant avec
martin pendant quelques heures il n'y a
qu'en dit il ya des fois sans l'immédiat
calimez ya pas qu une chambre dans un
hôtel ça tu me l'a pas dit non tu dors
avec quelqu'un excuse moi est ce que moi
je dors avec jonathan c'est un pote
comme martin maxence connais-tu wattpad
oui je connais depuis 2014 parce que il
ya des gens qui avaient écrit de fiction
entre cyprien est bon mais je suis sûr
et certain ya des failles de fiction
soit beau
[Musique]
voilà là dans mon lit lui qu'à cliquer
sur le bouton publier attend mec ya onze
chapitres
j'espère en tout cas que la personne qui
l'a fait déjà bravo tu ne nous en voudra
pas trop de le feuilleter surtout ne pas
avoir acheté maxence ouvrait doucement
les yeux il était seul dans le lit de
luca ce dernier avait déjà être levé je
veux dire elle sait pas écrire c'est moi
qui sait pas lire bah alors que c'est à
lui dit il avant que lucas ne l'ont lace
up vient de coucher à l'egypte a perdu t
on en parlera ok répondit doucement
lucas dans le cou de maxence c'est fou
ce qu'ils sentaient mots un mélange de
fleurs et de chupa chups étrange mais
tellement un pédant l'udc a retiré son
pantalon et ceux qui s'attend son livre
un tee-shirt et caleçon axe entre le
rejoignit de test dans les mains il est
posé sur chacune de leur table de nuit
retire a lui aussi son deviner semis
dans les 10 aux côtés de lucas ils
prirent chacun leur thé commencé à boire
maxence n'eut pas demander à luc à quoi
que ce soit comment ça tout lui raconter
il écoutait attentivement au moins 10
blessés - choix mais au moins tu n'as pu
être souciés de votre relation est votre
sentiment
maintenant tu vas t'occuper de citron
heureux pense pas tout ce qui vient de
se passer dit maxence opposant sa tasse
vide
oui et puis tu restes avec moi un
répondit-il opposants lui aussi sa tasse
de thé
évidemment dit il en s'approchant lui je
peux avoir un câlin demande à luc 1 en
souriant
ils s'endormir comme ça dans les bras
l'un de l'autre
c'est fou ce que dans la cei quelqu'un
pouvait luminaires d'esprit lucas se
sentait en sécurité
bouillot marquez et d'amour tandis que
maxence dépose en baisse alors max pons
avant ça il attrapa le visage de lucas
de ses mains tremblantes et des
positions s'élève en simple baiser au
début lucas ne savais pas comment réagir
il restait immobile les yeux clos il eut
du mal à réaliser ce qui était en train
de se passer
il ne s'y attendait pas même si c'était
ce qu'il voulait depuis des semaines
après réflexion il avait longtemps douté
et penser qu'intel baiser éclairer ses
sentiments mais là maintenant il n'était
pas encore sûr d'aimer maxence la
sensation que faisait le procurer était
alors sans trop réfléchir
il répondit doucement au baiser posant
ses mains sur la taille de maxence and
sand chaleur s'installe à on le baiser
s'intensifia est une expression de
sensations se fait ressentir au plus
profond d'eux les deux garçons se
perdent et se donner l'un pour l'autre
dans un baiser pourtant ces innocents la
porte du studio s'ouvrit sous le nom et
à cri de surprise ce filon tango lucas
max demanda carlito son visage affiché
en émotions de choc mais aussi de joie
ces deux derniers ne savaient plus
mettre les joues rougies par leurs
baisers et les cheveux en bataille comme
ça pourquoi le choix les gars vous êtes
ensemble oui le cam action serait pour
dire en même temps ils se regardaient
redoutant sans comprendre
purée péters non mais maxence regarda le
cas en souriant ils s'étaient compris
ils étaient a perdu mais était en
quelque sorte ensemble lucas santé qui
devenait de plus en plus rouge
je vais ouvrir à l'aide n'ont peut être
pas sachez où les gars je vous jure qu
avec david on n'attendait que ça les
faisant sursauter une pom girls bajeux
jeu lucas avait l'air plus gêné que
jamais bien qu'il était surpris c'est
pas méchant lucquin mais c'était à la
fois attendu et inattendu le cas
regardez maxence et fils qu'il souriait
du si il lui prit alors la main hésitant
maxence an lhasa leurs doigts ok comme
thomas semble en souriant de plus belle
avant de suivre raphaël
c'est pareil
alors pourquoi c'était comme ça face
caméra tu sais bien que j'ai passés
duras visant les gens comme ça j'ai du
mal jeu ouais mais je sais c'est moi qui
fais mon temps je n'ai tu pouvais quand
même être un peu plus fait moi vidéo
[ __ ] moi ici tu vas manquer ma puce
fort kent hughes a expliqué martin
[Musique]
qui
non
[Musique]